all right this weekend the far-left came
together to demand Trump's impeachment
it was not well attended anywhere we did
send our friend and our colleague and
investigative reporter our guy that hits
the streets hard Lawrence Jones to one
of the rallies this one in New York City
to ask okay why should the president be
impeached let's watch I'm here because I
believe in democracy and you believe the
president should be in peace I do why
yes he's an illegal president he's an
illegal president explained that for me
he was in he was in cahoots with the
Russians why do you believe the
president should be impeached because
some subjective justice I mean he's
committed really impeachable offenses if
there were any other president any
Democratic president any other even
Republican president he would have been
impeached in thrown out of office do you
believe the president should be
impeached no there's been investigation
after investigation they found nothing
he's been investigated more than any
other president
what crimes have we committed he was he
was with everything with uh with Russia
like in like he conned his way into the
office we've been putting up with an
illegal fake illegally elected president
for over two years
what crime do you suspect the president
has committed well number one conspiracy
with the Russians and then he covered it
up like like you can't believe me
why don't you think the Democrats have
brought up the articles of impeachment
it's a good question I wish I could read
policies mine but I can't do you believe
he's putting the country in real danger
yes everyday high every single day he
loves our country he's a good man
they want communism here well then go to
Venezuela and I'm very angry there was a
moment's vile racist vicious horrible
two men actually approached our own
Lawrence Jones and one told him to go
back to Fox News where this quote more
cotton for you to pick we don't have
that on tape but we do have the next
comment on tape take a look here now is
Fox News contributor editor-in-chief
campus reform Lawrence Jones we talk
Saturday I was pretty pissed off you
probably heard me in a way I don't
usually go on the air true or false but
I'm upset that that happened don't tell
us tell us what tell everybody what
happened I thought these are supposed to
be the the accepting loving wonderful
tolerant people on the Left apparently
not yeah this is who they are Sean you
know so often those of us that on the
right are painted as the racist people
the hateful people I mean you discuss
this all the time on your program and I
was just asking these people simple
questions about if they felt like the
president should be impeached or not
these guys come up to me and they say
you know go back to Fox News to pick
cotton they say go back to Kenya this is
who these people are but I doubt many
people in the media are gonna condemn
these people I don't the thing is I
don't think any of them will that's a
sad thing you know we've become friends
now over time and yeah I know it has
happened before it has happened - Danine
Borelli I mean she writes in her book
just google it I'll never forget that
and if you're it if you're black
in America and conservative for whatever
reason there's there's no holds barred
everything else is is oh we have to
watch it you have to say the politically
correct there's not even an ounce of
nicest kindness it's open season why is
that I frankly don't get it
yeah well see these guys are upset and
and they're fearful notice these were
not black people saying this this is the
white liberals sand these type of things
because they know that with our reports
and exposing the poverty and the failure
policies that all these Democrat cities
have been doing too many people that
look like me they don't want this to be
expose they believe that all black
people need to think it the same way
they want us to stay on the welfare
system so we can't progress in life and
I'm gonna expose it every single day if
they think that I'm gonna stand down
because they yelled obscene things to me
they got enough income but we're gonna
double down we're gonna go to all these
liberal cities all these presidential
candidates are gonna have the answer why
my community continues to be in poverty
why is that okay I you know what happens
every two four years but now it's like a
continuing loop cycle Republicans
conservatives racist sexist homophobic
xenophobic Islamophobic they want dirty
air water kill granny throw granny over
the cliff oh and by the way they hate
old people and young kids okay and every
one of it's true
but I look at the president's records we
have the best employment situation since
1969 okay
I'm a little bit older than you the Mets
won the World Series Lawrence in 1969
all right yeah you know what I know
you're young you're better looking
you're smarter I know we're friends you
can say whatever you want but look at
African Americans Hispanic Americans
Asian Americans women in the workplace
youth unemployment records for Trump not
providing Obama why do they think that
they have this hold on when you break
things down demographically why why
because I feel
the Republicans have failed to
communicate our message we have all the
policies we have all the policy
positions that help black America but we
don't go into those communities I think
the president needs it doesn't that
concern if he goes into the community
all right I think that's a great
analysis that should not happen I called
you on Saturday and I said listen you
don't have to do this and you said to me
are you kidding and I just want people
to know that you know I just admire your
strength your courage and your desire to
get out and you love there's other
people that love you and go up to
Lawrence and hug them and you know kiss
them on the cheek I've seen that too
I've seen that footage - Lawrence but
this should not happen and I'm sorry I'm
sorry my friend that that happened I am
truly sorry yeah I appreciate you
brother down love you too
all right we'll take a break we'll come
back won't forget Lawrence Jones Fox
Nation and his new show keep being up
with Jones available